الان هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور صلاح الدين
الزين الخبير في الشان السوداني دكتور
صلاح الدين اهلا بك ما هو الواقع الجديد
الذي فرضته هذه التطورات في السودان الان
شكرا جزيلا صباح الخير الساده المشاهدين
للحديث عن الواقع الجديد لابد من الاشاره
السريعه لملمى هذا النوع من الصراع الغير
مسبوق في السودان
للاسف ندخل يوم الثاني بالصراع يعني
يعني احدث من الدمار هنالك يعني ارواح
سقطت هنالك جرحى هنالك دمار ولكن الملمح
الاساسي انه هذا الصراع لاول مره انتشر في
الرقعه المدنيه داخل مدن السودان من اقصى
شرق السودان في بورسودان الى اقصى غربي في
الجنينه ومن اقصى الشمال في مروي الى اقصى
جنوب السودان وجنوب في مناطق النيل الازرق
مرورا بالعاصمه كل مدن السودان في ذات
اللحظه تعيش هذه الحاله الصراعيه
والاشتباكات المواطنين روعوا الاطفال
روعوا الناس ظلوا في في حاله من عدم
الطمانينه لساعات طويله ندخل اليوم الثاني
هذه مشكله كبيره جدا جدا طبعا الكل يتمنى
لو ان هذا الصراع ينتهي الان قبل بعده قبل
نهايه اليوم ولكن في واقع الامر هنالك
تعقيدات كبيره جدا في هذه الازمه الملمحه
الثانيه ان كثيرين يتحدثون ويخ الصراع في
انه هي قضيه تنافس بين الرجلين الجنرلين
عبد الفتاح البرهان وحمدي ولا يتحدثون عن
الازمه الحقيقيه البنيويه التي قادت لهذا
السرعه يجب ان لا ننسى ان عبد الفتاح
البرهان والجنرال كان حليفين الى وقت قريب
فما الذي ادى لكل هذا ليس طبعا هما
بالضروره يتنافسان كل منهم يبحث عن مجد
الشخصي ولكن هنالك اسباب جوهريه قادت الى
هذا الصرع وهو وجود المؤسسه العسكريه
الجيش السوداني الذي بدا يحس ان قوات
الدعم السريعه التي انشات لتكون ذراعا له
اصبحت قوه موازيه له واصبحت خارج السيطره
القوات المسلحه وربما عبد الفتاح البرهان
نفسه لم ياخذ هذه المواقف الا بضغط من
المؤسسه العسكريه لان لاحظنا قبل شهور
مواقفه كيف تغيرت فيما يتعلق بعلاقه
بالدعم السريع فكل الاطراف السياسيه
الداخليه والاقليميه والخارجيه الان الذين
فاشدون
بالطرفان يختصرونه في البرهان وحمايتي
للجلوس مع بعض للحوار ولا يتحدثون عن
الازمه الحقيقيه الازمه الحقيقيه ان الجيش
يرى ان هنالك قوه عسكريه ضخمه انشات
لمساندته واصبحت متمرده عليه خارج عن سلطه
الدعم السريع وبوصف الجيش لها بانها قوات
متمرده الان
ما الذي يمكن ان تشكله الان من ربما منافس
او خصم عسكري على الميدان للجيش اي واقع
سيولده ذلك بين طرفين على الارض طبعا
الخبراء العسكريين والمتابعون الميدانيون
يرون ان هنالك تفوق
كبير جدا للجيش السوداني على حساب الدعم
السريع وان هذه المواجهات لن تستمر طويلا
فقد تحسم عسكريا في على الاقل في داخل
المدن وفي مواقعه لكن هنالك تداعيات ستاتي
بعد اذا حسمت المعركه اليوم او غدا او بعد
غدا هنالك تداعيات وهذا يعتمد على اولا
على طبيعه التعامل المؤسسه العسكريه مع
هذه التداعيات التي ستفرزها هذه المعركه
هنالك تداعيات تتعلق
بالتكوين
الجغرافيه المناطقيه العرقيه لهذه القوات
اذا احسنت القوات المسلحه طريقه التعامل
معها فقد تمتص كثير من التداعيات السلبيه
التي قد تحدث هنالك ايضا تاثيرات على
العمليه السياسيه الجارحه حاليا في
السودان التي وقفت بسبب التباين طبعا
اختصرت ان القضيه فقط هي قضيه توقيتات
الدعم الدعم السريع الدمج الدعم السريع في
الجيش ولكن هي الجمهوريه زي ما ذكرت هو
شعور الجيش الدعم السريع اصبحت قوه موازيه
واصبحت حليف لتيار سياسي بعينه الان هل
قياده الجيش بعد اخذت هذا الموقف هل ستعود
لنفس طريقه اداره المرحله الانتقاليه
بالطريقه ما قبل هذه المعرفه ما قبل 15
ابريل ام انها ستتخذ خطا جديدا خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بجانب كان مهم جدا جدا هنالك شعور
متساعد لدى طبقه عريضه في الشارع السوداني
لدم داخل القوات المسلحه ان الاطراف
الاجنبيه
باتت تؤثر على المشهد السوداني بصوره
كثيفه جدا جدا يعني ليس هنالك دوله الان
على وجه البسيطه
تتنافس الاطراف الدوليه في اداره شانها
الداخلي كما يحدث في السودان وهذه قضيه
مزعجه جدا بالنسبه للجيش فهل سيستمر الجيش
في التعاطي مع الاطراف الخارجيه وان
الاطراف الخارجيه اذكر على سبيل المثال
هنالك الرباعيه وهنالك الاليه الثلاثيه
وهنالك الترويكا والغريب ان في دول بعينها
تجدها اعضاء في كل هذه المجموعات بريطانيا
على سبيل المثال هي عدو في الترويكا وهي
عضو في الرباعيه وهي ايضا وراء البعثه
الدولي التي تاتي في السودان هذه كلها
ستثير اسئله كبيره جدا هل سيستمر